[Music]
BTS takes over New York City the boys
took the stage on Good Morning America
on Wednesday in front of a crowd of
thousands all our friends are depressed
they are motivation we love your army
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah you heard that right
fans lined up days in advance camping
out in Central Park in the rain to
secure their spot at the free show
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday Monday that'll be seven days that
you slept out here just because it's
them we would literally sleep out here
for days and rain
what could I offer you money wise to
give me your tickets give me your spot
between their massive international
fandom and record-breaking hits the boys
of VTS are being compared to the Beatles
[Applause]
just like a dream
in fact the k-pop stars recently became
the first band since the Beatles to earn
3 billboard number-one albums in a
single year with their latest map of the
soul persona we're all fan boys a
Beatles of course but I mean who is not
and you know we are just feel so honored
to be with the greatest names in music
industry yes we love leaders of course
the group's new a single boy with love
featuring Halsey broke the record for
most watched video in 24 hours and RM
explained what the hit is all about it's
about finding finding little joy love
and being curious about the little
things the details in your life I wish
you doing what you're doing
I don't but most importantly boy enough
is like a fan letter from BTS army BTS
is currently on a worldwide stadium tour
love yourself speak yourself and
kicked-off GMA's 2019 summer concert
series in Central Park
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
naturally the army went crazy over the
performance
[Music]
BTS took the stage again for a
performance of their hit fire and it was
well fire
and while the band is at the top of
their game it's always been all about
their fans no are you looking we got
armies we got like thousands of
girlfriends today and here at Mike Ross
selfie arena so we don't worry no need
to or I mean tell me about arriving in
America at LAX and the fans when you
stepped off the plane so we never
expected like so much fans in the
airport belong to us a big so I really
like there were some photos of us and
he's like face like yes it was so nice
what do you think about kids not going
to school so they can see you play
without oh we're gonna have to talk
about soluble we're honorable for the
single bit again watch TV police sorry
but we're living in 2017 you can watch
on YouTube maybe later